[Applause]
all right New York City has a new
message for illegal immigrants go
someplace else oh they're overwhelmed uh
and it's nothing compared to Texas or
other border states now City officials
they're now passing out a flyer to
illegals warning them that New York is
one of the most expensive cities in the
world and that they are way better off
going to far less expensive place to
live now the new development but by the
way they don't give free fstar hotels
our veterans are homeless they don't get
any help but you're illegal immigrant
you're in a four or five star hotel in
New York anyway uh this comes as Texas
governor Greg Abbott visits the city of
New York to speak about the Border
crisis with a stark warning for people
in New York uh New Yorkers I know you're
probably out drinking and committing
crimes but take a look those of you that
are watching
what you're dealing with in New York
what you are seeing and witnessing in
the state is a tiny
fraction of what is happening every
single day in the state of
Texas all right and meanwhile just to
the south of here look at Philadelphia
look what what happened just a couple of
nights ago City suffering through two
night out of control looting and last
night look at your screen when you know
screens Windows broken shells emptied
total chaos but it's all just another
day in a big blue city or state isn't it
joining us right now his first Studio
appearance ever let's give a warm
welcome to Texas governor Greg Abbott
here you go
Governor now he's the Star Quarterback
so by the way we've been friends forever
um I think the world of you you know
it's very interesting you invited mayor
Adams uh and other New York politicians
to come to the border and see the border
for themselves uh they didn't come then
all of a sudden they realize it's going
to cost 122 billion in 18 months it's
costing
$440,000 per illegal immigrant New York
and now the even the governor saying if
you're going to come in the country
illegally don't come here wow how they
changed their tune exactly so what we've
seen is when Democrats have to face up
to the reality of what Texas has to do
with every single day they adopt the
same approach that Texas has we need the
president to start enforcing the
immigration laws of the United States of
America period and we're not going to
tolerate you know it's even worse than
not enforcing it the president has been
aiding and ab betting and the law
breaking you know I saw that they were
cutting holes in the wire that you're
footing the bill to put up to protect
your state and your and the cities the
border cities John and in all my life of
Public Service I've never seen anything
like what happened this past week with
what Joe Biden did because uh Texas has
built mile after mile after mile of
constantina razor wire barrier to
prevent illegal immigrants from coming
in and it worked they stopped coming in
yeah but but here's here's the deal
Biden's border patrol used cut wire
cutters to cut it open open it up and
thousands came in they are aiding and
abetting illegal entry into the United
States now all they want to do it seems
is take you to court are they giving you
any money any financial support no okay
now here's the thing you have tried I
have watched you you built Caravans you
s more agents in you youve you brought
your own people down there you've put up
barriers and every time you try to
protect the people of your state they
won't allow you to inforce what is the
law of this country right so I'll tell
you the most in Innovative thing that we
did were those buoys in the water uh
they were they were kind of designed and
created by the border patrol themselves
and the border patrol under Trump said
they would work and you know what they
do work and so we put them in the water
no one has crossed across those buoys uh
we're in a lawsuit right now if we win
that lawsuit we're going to have
hundreds of miles of buoys as a border
wall in the state of Texas okay that's
really
important but
can I ask you if I gave you the the
amount of money that they're claiming
it's going to cost the illegal immigrant
uh issue in New York City for example
and New York State and they're actually
thinking about only New York can think
of this because they're so dumb they
actually want an illegal immigrant new
tax so they want citizens to pay for
their amnesty their Sanctuary status I
mean by the way another reason to get
the hell out of here this this this is
easy math think of the dollars that New
York is spending on these bigr if they
take that same money and put it into
building the border wall securing the
Border New York would not be dealing
with the crisis they're dealing with
right now you know and recently mayor
Adams now you've invited mayor Adams to
come visit and and interesting he won't
come did are you have any chance to meet
with him I'll tell you funny story
because I love funny stories uh so the
the the city of New York was beside
itself about all these migrants being
bust to New York City and and so mayor
Adam sent operatives down to the border
to see what was going on and all these
migrants were in a room about this size
and they went in there and asked them
who here wants to go to New York
thinking that no one would do it
everyone raised their hand and they
about passed out cuz they knew what was
coming word got out they're putting him
in four or five star hotels why not I'd
take that deal right but the reality is
there's a lot of human suffering here
you know we have what while you you have
to put all your resources and
concentrate on the areas where you have
as many we had a record this past week
11,000 in a day 10,000 the day before
and all the resources are going to these
areas a high concentration of where it's
happening that gives the drug cartels
and the human traffickers free reign to
continue their multi-billion dollar
Enterprises that are killing our kids
correct and it's not just border states
here in New York City last week a
one-year-old child died because of
exposure to fentanyl deadly across the
entire country get this the Texas
Department of Public Safety alone has
seized more than enough fentel to kill
every man woman and child in the entire
United States of America deadly and
dangerous if if any of these New York
politicians have any guts would you
debate Governor hok would you debate
mayor Eric Adams because he was claiming
you're responsible for all the illegal
immigrants no your buses are responsible
for only 133% the 87% is actually Joe's
responsibility so I would like them to
come on this program meet with you and
have a one-on-one would you talk would
you do that I sure would that' be that'
be good for the country to see that
um I I just want you to know I i' I've
watched your career I've been a
supporter viers for a long time was very
happy when you got reelected uh you've
done a phenomenal job uh Governor uh
it's great to see you in studio please
don't be a stranger I know I wouldn't
want to leave Texas and come here but
thank you for doing it and maybe they'll
accept this uh debate you challenge both
of them to a debate absolutely all right
Governor Greg Abbott thank you
appreciate hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else